Your body is made up of over 200 bones,
a few trillion microbes, and
as many as 37 trillion cells.
And while death is often thought of as
the end of the line for your self,
your body still has a long way to go.
It doesn't take long before your body
starts to lose what makes you you.
Just a few minutes after death,
one of the first things
to go is your brain.
You see, when your heart stops beating,
it halts blood flow, which
is supposed to transport
oxygen to your organs and tissues.
So without blood, the most active,
oxygen-guzzling organs
and tissues go first.
And the results are...moist.
Because the cells that make
up those organs and tissues
are 70% water.
Without oxygen to keep them alive,
the cells self-destruct,
spilling all that fluid
onto the coffin floor.
By that night, an even more
troubling process begins
in the gut.
Your dying immune system
can no longer contain
the trillions of hungry
microbes that normally
help digest the food you eat.
So they escape.
First, they travel from
the lower intestines
through your tissues, veins, and arteries.
Within hours, they reach
your liver and gallbladder,
which contain a
yellow-green bile meant for
breaking down fat when you're alive.
But after the microbes are
through eating those organs,
that bile starts to flood the body,
staining it a yellow-green.
From about day two to four,
the microbes are everywhere.
And they're producing toxic gases,
like ammonia and hydrogen sulfide,
which will expand and cause your body
to not only bloat, but stink.
After three or four months,
your yellow-green complexion
has turned brownish-black
because your blood
vessels have deteriorated
to the point that the iron
inside them spills out,
becoming brownish-black as it oxidizes.
Also around this time,
the molecular structures that
hold your cells together break away,
so your tissues collapse
into a watery mush.
And in a little over a year,
your cotton clothes disintegrate,
as acidic body fluids and
toxins break them down.
Only the nylon seams
and waistband survive.
At this point, nothing
dramatic happens for a while.
But by a decade in, given enough moisture,
the wet, low-oxygen environment
sets off a chemical reaction
that turns the fat in your thighs and butt
to a soap-like substance called grave wax.
On the other hand, drier
conditions lead to mummification.
That's right, you can mummify naturally.
No wrappings, chemicals,
or intimidating instruments required.
Because throughout this
entire decomposition process,
water is evaporating through the thin skin
on your ears, nose, and
eyelids, causing them to dry
out and turn black, aka mummify.
By 50 years in, your
tissues will have liquefied
and disappeared, leaving behind
mummified skin and tendons.
Eventually these too will disintegrate,
and after 80 years in that coffin,
your bones will crack as the soft collagen
inside them deteriorates,
leaving nothing but the
brittle mineral frame behind.
But even that shell won't last forever.
A century in, the last of your bones
will have collapsed into dust.
And only the most durable
part of your body,
your teeth, will remain.
Teeth, grave wax, and some nylon threads.